the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from a trailer breakdown video for
the game of thrones season 8 finale
it's a little hard to believe we are
only days away from watching the very
last episode of the series
i know many of you have wondered what i
will do after game of thrones is over
i will definitely continue to make
videos once the show does end
and i do understand that some of you
might not want to watch my videos after
game of thrones is over but like i said
i want to continue making videos either
way
i do want to thank everyone that has
supported the channel thus far
but anyways let's talk about the season
8 finale the first thing i want to do is
look at the different images from the
trailer then during the second half of
the video i want to talk about the leaks
if you do not want to hear about those i
will let you know when you should turn
off the video
these leaks are becoming unavoidable
right now because everyone keeps leaving
them in the comments section
and i have even seen some other
youtubers make videos about them
so i might as well talk about them since
i've already seen them now let's look at
the images from the final trailer
this begins right where we left off in
the last episode as you all know
daenerys targaryen had finally set her
sights on king's landing and the iron
throne
cersei lannister did have the
opportunity to surrender before anyone
had to die but she decided to reinforce
king's landing
in her army as well cersei thought she
had a good chance of winning the battle
daenerys and john did lose a lot of
their soldiers during the battle of
winterfell
and not to mention dany only had one
dragon so it did seem like cersei had a
chance since she had so many scorpions
set up around the city
it did seem like this could be one hell
of a final battle but shortly after it
started it became very obvious that
cersei would not stand a chance
this was about as one-sided as you could
get daenerys and drogon could not be
stopped
even after cersei's men surrendered
danny and drogon leveled the entire city
as well as any civilian that could not
find stable shelter
it ended up becoming a slaughter john
and tyrion could not believe
what they were witnessing as daenerys
and drogon started to murder thousands
of innocent civilians
as you can see by the first image from
the new trailer we can see the aftermath
of the battle for king's landing
it almost looks as if someone set off an
atomic bomb
the streets are covered by nothing but
skeleton and ash
it looks very similar to a nuclear
fallout there is nothing left
and this just goes to show you what a
dragon can actually do
drogon was able to decimate an entire
city and you have to wonder where do we
go from here
you can see john and davos walking
around the street and i'm assuming they
are shocked by what is actually left
after the battle
these are the kind of images that would
haunt you for the rest of your life
now we all know they have been in
battles before and they even seen the
night king resurrect thousands of dead
bodies but they've never seen
anything quite like this i cannot wait
to see what it said to dany when they
finally have a chance to talk
we haven't actually seen dany's face
since the bell started to ring in king's
landing
after she took off on drogon we never
saw her face again
all we could see was the dragon burning
everything in sight
i do wonder how dany was reacting to the
things she was actually doing to all the
civilians below her who were running for
their lives
we also see tyrion lannister walking
around the streets of the city
this was once a city that he called home
now it looks like what can only be
described as a living nightmare
the smell of burnt flesh must be heavy
in the air as well as the screams and
cries of whoever
if anyone that were able to survive this
devastating attack
i will also be very interested in
getting to see what he has to say to
daenerys
in another one of these photos we can
see that the red keep was not completely
level to the ground
it does look like most of the castle is
still intact although we do know the
ceiling is gone in some of the areas
this is definitely setting up to be very
reminiscent of daenerys targaryen's
vision at the house of the undying
this is something i have talked about in
many of my other videos before
i always had a feeling that vision could
become a reality but i did not think
daenerys would lay waste to the entire
city
i always thought her main focus would be
on the red keep since that's where
cersei would most likely try to hide
during the battle
we can see the castle again in this
image but this time we can see some of
danny's army right out front as they are
celebrating their victory over cersei
we can also see arya stark as she slowly
makes her way to the front of the red
key
i'm also very interested in getting to
see what arya stark does next
as we all know daenerys almost killed
arya several times during the attack
now to be fair dany might not have known
arya was down there in the street but i
don't think arya will give a damn either
way
in those moments arya became one of the
civilians in king's landing
she even tried to help a mother and her
child during the attack
and unfortunately arya had a front row
seat at just how relentless danny was
during the battle
arya already told jon that she did not
trust dany so i can't wait to see what
she thinks of her now
i would like to think arya will want to
see her dead some fans say that it will
even be arya who kills daenerys
targaryen
now obviously i do not know for a fact
if it will be arya that kills dany but i
think it's safe to assume that she might
want to
go ahead and take a look at arya's face
i'm guessing she is looking right
through dany
as she walks back out of the red key i
can only imagine what kind of dark
thoughts are running through arya's head
the only thing that makes me think arya
will not kill dany is because of what
sandor clegane said to her during their
final conversation
he tried to make arya come to the
realization that she doesn't want to
become him
arya should not live her entire life
where she is basically only motivated by
getting her revenge
not to mention i don't think arya will
have to be the one to kill danny because
i am confident there will be several
other characters that want to see her
dead
either way i do want to hear what arya
has to say most of the other characters
who were here for the battle either died
in the red key
or they got out of the city before dany
ended up killing them
arya is the one character we know was
nearly killed by drogon on several
different occasions
i would like to see arya say something
about this to jon as well
i would like to see jon's reaction after
arya tells him how danny almost killed
her in the attack
we can also see terry lannister looking
at someone or something
this could also be when daenerys is
walking back out of the red keep
it's obvious he is not happy by the
decision danny made
we know that she did agree to stop the
attack as soon as the bell started to
ring
will he continue to stand by danny's
side after she done something like that
we also have to see what dany says to
tyrion it's only a matter of time before
she finds out that he was the one that
let jaime out of the chains
she did tell him he would no longer be
getting any second chances
so he might be mad at her but she will
also be mad at him and by the looks of
the city
i doubt tyrion is as mad as danny he
could become the next character who gets
executed by danny and jurgon
but we shall see these other images are
basically just the unsolid standing in
formation
and the dothraki celebrating their
victory the last image is somewhat
disturbing
the city is essentially gone and
daenerys is walking out to address her
soldiers
and maybe even a few survivors from the
attack there is something about this
image that makes me think danny will be
very happy about what she had just done
she always wanted the iron throne and
now she has it
now she has to ask herself was it worth
it
once again i am very interested in
getting to hear what danny has to say
i wonder if she will try to justify her
actions or if she will show any remorse
to the civilians that died
considering what she has done it's hard
to see how daenerys can have any type of
happy ending after this
now that dany has shown herself to be
extremely unstable
i don't see how anyone can continue to
allow her and drogon to be together
they make for one hell of a dangerous
and deadly combination
one of them if not both of them will
have to die there is no way you would be
able to guarantee this would not happen
again if you let them live together
that would be like letting a mass
shooter keep their gun it would only be
like a matter of time before they would
end up doing it again
now i want to move on to the leaks like
i said if you do not want to know how it
actually ends i will turn off the video
right now
so far whoever let out the information
has been incredibly accurate
i will leave the link in the description
on my video in case any of you want to
go and read it on your own
as far as i can tell this seems to be a
legitimate leak from an inside source
i say that because they even knew some
of the small details that no one would
have guessed on their own
for instance they knew that the night
king's dragon would have a blue flame
coming out the side of its neck
after it was injured they knew sandor
clegane would stab his brother right in
the eye
they knew arya would be running around
the streets of king's landing trying to
hide from the dragon
these are the kind of details that none
of us have been guessing
i've been making videos for a long time
and so have some other game of thrones
youtubers and none of us have seen
anyone making these kind of guesses
before the episodes came out
so like i said this leak seems to be
extremely accurate
alright so in the final episode we
should see danny give a speech at some
time
this might be what we're about to see in
the new trailer it does seem like that
is what dany is about to do
whatever she says will make some of the
other characters very angry
danny will want to go all over
liberating slaves from their masters by
burning down other cities
it sounds like king's landing might only
be the beginning of what dany now wants
to do
they say that tyrion will be very upset
so he takes off his hand of the queen
pin
and he throws it down on the ground dany
will have him arrested
and she will also want him to be
executed for letting jaime go free
now it doesn't say if this next thing
happens before or after he is arrested
but he will eventually try to convince
jon that he and his family will no
longer be safe since his claim is a
threat for the iron throne
basically as long as dany is alive jon
and his family will not be safe now that
dany is killing anyone she thinks is a
threat
it doesn't actually say if dany sits on
the iron throne or not but it does say
she gets to see it
that seems about right since the red
keep wasn't completely knocked down
it also looks like dany is walking back
outside in that scene so my guess is
that's where she was coming from
maybe she walks up to it and turns
around like we saw in the vision
it does say the iron throne will be
melted down by the dragon
before that happens it also says john
and arya will have a conversation right
in front of the iron throne
we know that jon and arya are still in
this city and we even seen arya right in
front of the red keep so this does seem
like it could happen
maybe arya says something to john about
danny further convincing him that danny
will need to be dealt with
although i'm sure john already knows
that then it says john will try to talk
to danny
but she will only justify all of her
actions when jon realizes there is no
stop in dany he will get close enough to
stab her with his sword
so it looks like jon will be the one to
kill dany not only because he was
horrified by what dany had done to
king's landing but also because she
continues to say that she is not done
like i said she wants to go to other
cities and basically do the same thing
so after jon kills danny he will leave
king's landing and live out the rest of
his life in the north
this indicates that jon will go back to
castle black
this may have even been foreshadowed
when jon and tormund last spoke
not to mention that is where jon sent
ghosts so maybe they will be reunited
in the end it says the reason why jon
decides to do this is because it will
give up his claim to the iron throne
essentially it will be exactly like what
maester aemon did when he was in line
for the iron throne
maester aemon even said that story to
jon snow so that may have been
foreshadowing all the way back in the
first season
now that dany is dead and jon is out of
the way the other characters will be
left to decide how things are operated
from here on out
it says that bran stark will become the
next king of westeros
then characters like sansa davos sam and
maybe some others will be on his council
it says the unsullied will leave to go
back across the narrow sea to start
liberating slave cities because that's
what danny wanted right before she was
killed
one of the biggest scenes from the
episode will be when tyrion lannister is
on trial at the dragon pit
there will be a lot of other characters
there during this scene
it says john and danny are not there
most likely because dany is dead and jon
has already went to the north
brian stark will do the same thing that
he did to littlefinger
he knows that tyrion once said he will
never bet against his family
once a lannister always a lannister it
says he will be executed but since this
scene was shot inside of the studio
they do not know exactly how he dies
arya stark will leave king's landing
most likely never to be seen again so
this looks like this is how the season
will come to an end
since they had basically everything else
right i will assume this is right as
well
let me know what you think will happen
in the finale leave your thoughts down
below
anyways i want to thank you all for
watching the video and i also want to
thank everyone for supporting the
channel
i hope you have a great day i will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
so
you